let me put it to you this way Brianna
Taylor and George Floyd funded the
departments that killed them and what I
mean by that is our tax dollars go to
the Department of Justice who issues
grants to these departments we don't
have any clawback mechanisms but these
departments have no transparency have no
civilian oversight we don't know their
training mechanisms but yet our tax
dollars go to them and so I think that
we I'm not saying the fund but what I am
saying is that we need to have some
accountability measures in place with
our tax dollars to go to this deeply so
this is my proposal that I I put out on
social media and some people loved it
actually got much more love than
anything else so if you take as a given
that local district attorneys and
officials are going to have a hard time
confronting police misconduct in their
area because of the incestuous
relationships that you just described
and you need someone independent now now
I looked at the Department of Justice
guidelines and after the Rodney King
riots they passed a law saying that that
the Department of Justice can
investigate police departments for
systemic problems as they did with the
LAPD as a practice in it but you know
violating constitutional rights and
equal rights that happens very very
seldom it's happened I believe once in
the entire Trump administration and it
strikes me as willfully insufficient so
the proposal is that you have a new
police misconduct Division of the
Department of Justice that's dedicated
just to answering complaints and
investigating police misconduct if you
were a really good DA or mayor you
actually welcomed this cuz you're like
oh good like you know I didn't want to
have to pick a fight with like the the
local law enforcement but the feds are
here you name it after George Floyd you
fund it and then you have an army of
investigators who are just following up
to see you know it's like hey there are
a lot of complaints against this Derek
Chavan character like 18 of them you
know it's
or you're coming in hopefully before the
fact you're completely immune from
political influence your job is just to
try and root out bad cops I suggested
that Val Demmings run it someone that
people would be excited about because
she has a law enforcement background and
and you know and so because and then
most people saw this proposal and said
like yes that this could be he could be
on to something here other people took
the like like no we should defund
essentially like what your original
which like I looked at it and say look
they're 18,000 police departments around
the country getting funded in all sorts
of ways by like municipalities and
property tax on the rest of it it's it's
like like I understand the impulse but
it to me it's much more practical to
actually like agree up someone who's
like an independent actor who doesn't
have ties to community their entire
measurements are just around trying to
root out please misconduct and then you
could also get better data because you'd
have a department that's dedicated to it